the boy he wasn't before like in
self-isolation around 20 days
between april since we arrived until
maybe the middle of june
and that in the end of june he was
saying like the people against him the
people hate him
like the next room there was making some
noise he was saying the noise he was
just to disturb him the room and the top
of him the same like
it's normal because the wallet was like
gibbs and the room like
i can hear my next room everyone can
hear each other and he was saying that
they are against him
suddenly one day he said i want to
attack them
i want to attack that room next to me
that room in the top of me
and he said i want to attack the the
hotel workers we i sent him not need
it's
no logic to do that everyone it's fine
just try to
ignore everything we said everyone no no
no one was happy inside
i said them exactly what he said that he
he want to attack
tomorrow he wants to attack but we don't
know when but because he have like we
said them like he start to feel everyone
against him
i said just i want to warn we don't know
what could happen
the reception he said okay i will take
it seriously and i will make the report
and like i i don't know what happened
come and see us inside anyone
everyone waiting the moment to explode
we are in the hotel
as a prisoners i know this is what i'm
saying they don't like it meers
but in the hotel we have every timing
for everything if i didn't
if i would not be in the hotel from one
to three i would not find my lunch
and the dinner the same from six to
eight if i would not be there i'll not
find my dinner
and after the dinner sometimes it's hard
to get drinks or food
so everyone like in stress like they
cannot go out because they
have time and they cannot sit in the
room because it's everything in that
room they eat they sleep they wake up
everything in the same place